[Music]
foreign
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I'm Piers Morgan and censor tonight A
demonstrator is shockingly punched to
the ground as public patients with just
stop oil protests runs dry can vigilante
virus ever be justified and where were
the police
Nigel farage divides opinion as a
rabble-rousing politician and
enthusiastic amateur broadcaster but
does he really deserve to have his bank
account shut down we'll debate whether
companies have that right to choose who
they do business with
plus a slew of Stars play mental
Gremlins of public meltdowns and career
calamities influential figures like Joe
Rogan and Jordan Peterson say we should
maybe think about toughening up I'll be
living through a mental health crisis or
a crisis of mental strength will debate
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored well
good evening London welcome to Piers
Morgan uncensor just stop all protesters
who I'm beginning to loathe with a rare
passion I have to say are becoming a
part of everyday British life they were
just an irritating novelty at first
privileged Gap year hobbyists and silly
orange t-shirts but they've turned into
a full-blown Tangerine nightmare not a
day seems to pass now without a mandarin
Menace attacking a sports event or
shutting down a public road Cricket
football Formula One snooker galleries
Banks the Chelsea flower show Wimbledon
the problems you name it they've tried
to ruin it and these protests have
liberated because we've allowed them to
we say they're irritating we say they're
irresponsible we say they're harming
their claws but by and large we let them
get away with it more importantly so do
the police you might remember Daniel nor
a couple of weeks ago he spelled a test
match at Lords that I was personally
enjoying at the time in Johnny bestow
carried him off like he was packing away
his ironing board and then dumped him
over the bounds like a garbage sacking
good for Johnny but today well Mr nor
was back for more he took part in a slow
walk protest in London which reportedly
caused a pregnant woman to crash her car
and her boyfriend then stepped in to
avenge what happened the video is
shocking I have to warn you
[Music]
what a shocking incident uh to be clear
I don't condone the violence I don't
think motor should take the law into
their own hands but where exactly is the
law where were the police I can
sympathize with the anger someone feels
if they're trying to go about their day
to get to a hospital appointment or to
see their families all the anger of
someone who sees his pregnant partner
involved in a collision because of a
protest and then an argument in the
street with those protesters now never
done anything wrong they're not pumping
oil they're just trying to get to work
public anger with these protests is
simmering to Boiling Point in the
absence of Common Sense policing this is
going to inevitably be the results a
growing number of protesters are simply
dealing with themselves it's only a
matter of time before one of them get
seriously injured the best way to
prevent that is possibly this
foreign
[Applause]
well that's how they do it in Germany uh
No Nonsense just get them out the way
and that's how we should be doing it
here in my view if just stop oil won't
stop being complete pratts to put it
mildly the police should step up and
save them from themselves well joining
me now is the author Grace Blakely and
best-selling author of the war on the
West Douglas Murray over in the states
all right Grace but as I've said
repeatedly from the start of this I have
a lot of sympathy and agreement with the
cause of just stop oil I think climate
change is real I think there are real
problems facing this planet that we need
to deal with and so on but these
protests the way they're going about
them they are not bringing people with
them they are alienating the very people
they should be trying to persuade I
don't get it the more they do it the
more they're infuriating the public I
don't see anyone saying great they've
ruined my day I must come and join them
they've already achieved their aim which
is to get us to talk about it you know
half the time that I come on shows the
lead item is something to do with the
culture walls it's you know something
about trans rights or some bathroom
issue or whatever and we've just had the
hottest week recorded in history we've
seen temperatures in Europe rise to
Heights that we've never seen in history
these people literally want to set the
agenda and that is what they're doing
and the thing that scares me the most
we've had a lot of debates in the past
about free speech about actually you
know the state overstepping the mark and
when I see videos like that of people
literally you know the arms of the state
literally dragging people off the
streets and saying you're not allowed to
be here you should be doing this no but
they're allowed that's worried about it
but that strikes me as a threat to civil
liberties no but this is this is where
the problem is because I've got no
problem exercising their right into Free
Speech or peaceful protest I don't think
they have a right to ruin everyone well
no no to ruin people's fun days out
they've saved maybe all year to go and
see at the cricket or the flower show or
whatever it may be I don't think
Ordinary People should have their days
ruined in that way nor do I nor do I
think they should be blocking roads like
Vauxhall Bridge which lead down to one
of them
finish
that lead down to one of the busiest
hospitals in London if not the country I
don't think they should be stopping
people going to and from hospitals
there's no legitimate reason to be doing
that
these people are aware of the fact that
the main like segment of people who are
dying from climate breakdown are
extremely poor people who live in the
global South places like the north of
India but Pakistan
um that area of the world where you've
seen temperatures get up to like
temperatures that scientists say it is
not possible for human habitation why
are they protesting over there well
because they live here and we are the
ones we are the countries that have
historically admitted the most
the countries that are in the global
South where poor people are dying why do
we never see them in China we the
biggest polluters in the world we have
the power in this country in Europe in
America in the most powerful countries
in the world in the richest countries in
the world to change things China has
actually done a lot already 98 of them
China
are the biggest polluter in the world
and you never see Incredible or any just
stop all protesters in China how did we
get rich you know why because in China
they get a very different treatment
let me go to Douglas uh Douglas I'm not
about you I just find them unbelievably
irritating and increasingly so I think
there are a bunch of attention Seekers
who love just getting in the papers and
that's fine but why is the state and the
police tolerating it in the way that we
seem to be
well I'd go slightly further than your
peers I mean they are a sort of end time
apocalyptic cultist movement of a kind
that londoners and others have seen
throughout history people who go
jibbering through the streets screaming
about the imminence of the apocalypse
and I don't have much time for their
views and I think that their method of
protest increasingly of course means
that uh more and more members of the
public don't have much time for their
views freedom of speech of course
everyone defends it freedom of protest
everyone defends it but you do not have
a right I I have strong views and a
whole range of things I don't have the
right to go and sit in the middle of the
M24 and tell everyone else uh to go you
know hang whilst I decide to tell them
how they should go about their day or
ruin their day I'd be hauled off the
motorway in a moment or quite rightly so
that the freedom to protest doesn't
extend to disrupting the lives of
everyday people trying to go about their
business
and I I just I just can't understand why
they think that they're advancing their
cause uh uh I I at any rate think that
we still haven't had one even reasonable
person uh emerge from the just stop oil
and etc etc movement every time you get
one on there is a gibbering wreck well
also they get very abusive very quickly
and turn it all very personal when in
fact I try and explain I don't think
your methods are working but I agree
with a lot of the message and so it's a
campaign I think we get much more public
support if they weren't just being so
deliberately irritating to the public
and obstructive to the Public's ability
to go about your day-to-day life I mean
I think that incident today where you
saw a guy who's in a car with his
apparently his pregnant partner and they
get I think hit by a lorry behind them
so it's a collision a crash and she gets
out this pregnant lady is demonstrating
the thing and this guy clearly loses his
rag now the violence he then commits is
unacceptable and most people would agree
with that but I can certainly understand
why he's reached a point of boiling rage
and yeah well where are the police here
this protest has been going on for God
knows how long that morning why are the
police not intervened to stop this
particular incident then happening it's
because of the guidance that the British
police have had in recent years has
consistently been to protect the
protesters from the general public
rather rather than protecting the
general public from having their lives
repeatedly do you remember what happened
we had protests around the murder of
Sarah Rivera do you remember the police
treatment of those women there yeah I
remember very well in fact and this
continuously happens quite a lot we have
astonishingly now Draconian rules about
protest and it was not that long ago I
remember where you know a lot of the
subjects and debates that we would have
been having was about are the left
snowflakes they want to shut everyone
down they want to cancel everyone we you
know want to protect Free Speech what
happened to the Free Speech Defenders
the right to protest is genuinely at
risk
in this country
to them causing literally as in today
with this incident that was a false
equivalent right there incredibly uh
people are trying to go about their day
and there are people basically literally
standing here saying all I want to do is
highlight the fact that there are going
to be Millions hundreds of millions of
people who will die if we don't change
course right now and you say but look we
all have we all have strong views we all
have strong views on a wide range of
subjects as it happens the policing of
the Sarah Everett case was it was a
classic case of the police getting it
wrong everybody admits that a
commissioner had to step down after it
that was people protesting peacefully as
it happened during a period of lockdown
but the point is with with the with the
just of oil people is they do have a
kind of protection because it seems that
the advice that the police have
repeatedly given uh the the leader of
the police forces in Britain has been
that because climate change has become
such an obsession of so many people in
Britain you might lose public uh
Sympathy for the police if the police
were seen to be cracking down we're
going to move on to the second party
we're going to move on but I all I would
say is I think it's time the police got
these protesters off busy Street
honestly I think otherwise otherwise
what you're going to see I'm seeing a
rising number of incidents of the public
yeah taking the Law into their own hands
and we're going to end up we're going to
end up in a very bad situation which
will be a lot worse than the video we
saw today I can guarantee it if someone
is stopping someone getting their you
know their wife may be dying and they're
racing at a hospital and they get
stopped by just stop oil protests
there's going to be a very unpleasant
most people on the right are actually
very liberal and this is actually going
to be interesting when we move on to
this next thing everyone says we want a
small state but when it's the state
stamping itself
thank you Grace uh but you team me up
nicely so this is about Nigel farage who
is well he's an amateur broadcaster and
his new life but he is also a well-known
politician now he claimed that documents
have proved that Coots Bank have closed
his account due to his views on brexit
Donald Trump and gender ideology the
bank whose clients include members of
the royal family and myself initially
denied that was the case and brief that
perhaps farage didn't have enough money
you've got to have a certain amount of
money to have a Coots account but
according to the former brexit party
leader 10 other banks have refused his
custom prime minister Rishi sunak has
condemned it today stating that no one
should be barred from using basic
services for the political views adding
a free speech it's a Cornerstone to our
democracy so Grace an interesting case
when you get into the weeds of the
documents which were published by the
telegraph today it's the reasons
apparently are twofold one is that uh
Nigel's says I want to make you aware of
a commercial exit decision being made
about uh Nigel farage the relationship
has been below commercial criteria for
some time and upon review of Nigel's
past public profile connections the
perceived risk for the future waiting
against the benefit of attention the
decision was taken to exit upon
repayment of an existing mortgage now it
turned out that that existing was
apparently was paid off hence their
decision to say we're no longer going to
allow them to become a to stay as a
client did they make a decision risk
factors included accusations of links to
Russia controversial public statements
which were left to conflict with the
bank's purpose and the possibility
speculated in the press and not denied
of re-entry to politics taken into
account there is however also clearly a
risk of negative publicity in exiting
which was accepted so that's the broad
brush Strokes here where partly they've
used the excuse he no longer has them
amount of money you need to have a coup
to Gap I can attest you have a certain
amount so that may be partly true but
clearly another motivating factor were
his political views to which I would say
I don't agree with a lot of what Nigel
farage says politically but I don't
understand why he shouldn't be allowed
an accountant Coots if I am well I have
strong opinions about awesome things
um Mr farage believes in a free market
and businesses within a free market have
the right to make decisions about
services and go to the willow what is
that right based on supply and demand
should a major Bank be using someone's
political views I mean look they his
relationship with Donald Trump Donald
Trump the market doesn't care about your
feelings the market doesn't care about
anything it is just risk and reward it's
supply and demand and if you believe in
a world that is governed by the logic of
the market you have absence
of course but the market doesn't
guarantee the market doesn't guarantee
you should know who has the public said
and if it was up to me I believe we
should have a public banking system in
which everyone is guaranteed different
issues it is a very just to clarify just
to clarify you think should have the
right to do is fine I don't believe that
because I don't believe in a free market
okay but Nigel farage does but do you
believe that Nigel Farrell should be
disallowed or have his account
discontinued because of his political
views given your adherence to free
speech you've just been banging all
about I think that we should have a
public banking system in which everyone
is
de facto should he be allowed to have an
accountant Coots because of his
political view we live in a capitalist
economy if a private bank says because
of perceived political risk we aren't
going to give an account to someone then
ultimately either you say we live in a
free market Society they have the right
to do that or you say we shouldn't live
in a freezer and he shouldn't have the
right not free speech okay
it doesn't guarantee free speech I
understood
before you speak I want to play a clip
Nigel far is talking about this and then
come to you
commentary and behaviors that do not
align with the bank's purpose and values
have been demonstrated
so the bank has a series of values the
bank has a series of political positions
and as for purpose well I thought the
purpose of companies was to act
ethically yes of course but to return to
their shareholders dividends and in this
case folks do you know who the
shareholders are it's you and me
all right Douglas your view of this
well first of all it's always delicious
when a socialist sets up a binary uh in
the way that Grace just did if there's
something bad in capitalism the only
alternative is socialism of course it is
it always is for socialists isn't it but
it is lovely here in Grace
it's lovely hearing Grace defend Coots
bank it's a terrific position for a
socialist to be in uh look I would put
it the most important the most important
the most important thing in this is the
old shoe on the other foot uh scenario
isn't it peers here's here's a good
example I mean grace was a supporter of
Jeremy corbyn Jeremy corbyn led a very
racist period in the labor party's
history where female Jewish MPS were
hounded out of the party and the
equality and Human Rights Commission
found that the labor party had a serious
problem with racism now here's the thing
I don't agree with anything that Jeremy
corbyn believes probably enough no more
than I agree with anything that great
this beliefs but if Coots bank I don't
know if if Mr Corbin would bank with
Coots but whoever he banked with if they
said that because of Mr Corbin's
association with racists and racism and
terrorists and so on he shouldn't be
allowed to have a bank in the UK I would
defend him to the hilt because I know
where this goes the Canadian government
uh Ultra dippy Trudeau in Canada has
presided over a system in the last 18
months in which if you're an opponent of
his government and actually come out and
protest as people did last year you can
get debanked just think about that again
for a moment we're talking about
protests earlier that if you protest
against the government you can lose the
right to Bank in the cashless economy so
here's the thing we know where this
leads that we know where this leads that
anyone who believes in Freedom including
freedom of the press freedom of speech
and much more should care
particularly opposed other people even
when they're political foes who they
would love to kick in the nuts get it
they should defend those people right
how might we think we're an economy in
which everyone has the right to a bank
account as a basic human right you have
the right to a bank account there's no
way you can get unbanked yeah okay
it clearly is that is a debate for
another day it's really not here's what
I was here's what I would say about
pertinent Nigel Farrell out of his way
to try and wreck my opening night
interview with Donald Trump for this
show over a year ago he literally went
to Trump with all the worst things I
said about Trump in the previous year
and said look at this you can't do the
interview and Trump nearly pulled the
plug so I have absolutely zero reason to
say anything supportive of Nigel farage
and he works for a rival Network as a
amateur broadcaster
um again that's another reason not to
say anything nice about him however I've
got to say as a Coots customer myself I
find this very concerning and I rang
them today to us I remind them to ask to
speak to him today when they they said
they couldn't talk about it because by
doing so they would be providing
information about a client I presume
they mean but here's my point about it I
have what some people consider
controversial views I don't think
they're controversial but I have quite
strong views about other things I'm not
quite sure why his are deemed less
acceptable in terms of being a banking
customer in the UK the mind I may not
agree with him about a number of things
I'm just not sure why I tick boxes and
he doesn't when it comes to a right to
have an opinion
a free democracy it could be you
tomorrow appears it could be Grace the
day after me the day after that yeah
okay based on an assessment of risk
which it has very professional people to
do they do it said it is going to
potentially over the Run damage our
profits if we offer this personal backup
this is a decision that back every day
no no
having read the full details that
appeared in the telegraph today I don't
think there are grounds
but ultimately
public don't forget that Coots lied and
briefed a lie to the BBC which the BBC
then reported they're not interested in
the truth that Coots I'd get your money
out peers
well we'll see I'm actually gonna I'm
gonna hope to speak to them and get some
answers to some questions I'm genuinely
interested and concerned about how far
they take this how far are my opinions
going to be one day right nationalized
raccoons right you know what goes
on the same page
as always thank you I renew a Grace
great to see you twice running and I'm
spoiled uh thank you thank you for being
back today uncensored next tonight Tory
took MP Tobias Elwood as we criticized
we're saying we need to talk to the
Taliban I'll be holding talks with him
after the break
thank you
[Music]
good evening I'm Peters Morgan I'm
censored in New York City tonight on
Piers Morgan uncensored in Kiev Ukraine
tonight on Piers Morgan on Central
Edition tonight a special edition
appears more than unsensitive Martina
navratulations do you believe you can
win this war so are you gonna run again
I think a lot of people are going to be
very happy yes I feel betrayed they're
trying to force you out yes not only the
coach but the other two or three guys
there around all these people protesting
just don't get it many of them don't
isn't that slightly patronizing
do you think we should have psychiatric
assessment I'd be there for weeks did
you keep quiet I'm trying to read a book
thanks bear and Chuck it where it
belongs in the bin
let's see where are they where's their
children
it's from that much cushier gel that
galane Maxwell agreed to be interviewed
for the very first time I obviously wish
I'd never met him you're shaking
is out as British prime minister the
conservative party can certainly win the
next election can we yes
this is the royalty question is did he
say yes I have taken drugs and they bent
the rules to give them the Visa or lied
on the visa application form and
therefore got it
[Music]
what does a woman me
let it roll a woman is given to the man
in marriage Andrew You're simply wrong
I've been a terrible liar that's true I
mean would you be prepared to say that
I've been a terrible liar are you sorry
you said that
I think it matters you should be
absolutely not you should be interview
adjourned
which is your favorite nickname that
Trump's giving us Rhonda sanctimonious
or meatball Rock I've seen you clown
Tommy Fury so please go easy on me bro
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I have nothing to hire
I'm the only one that has been telling
the truth and you had to come up against
a team that had a Russian player would
you shake that with no chance no chance
it's life and death This Is War Pass
Morgan
what went wrong she said well I've only
got two years and I said you'll have two
months if you carry on like this what's
your response to him the whole nation
deserves to know what happened you don't
drink never taken drugs you're stinking
Rich should we be concerned
real opinions real debate is about you
and your opinions if you're thinking
about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that's a joke
foreign
[Music]
people in the hands of the ruthless
Taliban the Hardline regime has swiftly
stripped women of their basic human
rights to work school or even travel on
their own conservative MP Tobias Elwood
the chair of the defense select
committee is under five for visiting the
country releasing a video it's been
described as looking as sounding like a
tourism advert for the Taliban well
Tobias Elwood joins me now uh Tobias
Elwood
um I was going to say I'll watch this uh
video
um let's take a little look at parts of
it and I'll come to you after that
all that's happened here since 9 11.
this is a very different country in deal
it feels different now that the Taliban
have returned to power well it may be
hard to believe that security has vastly
improved corruption is down and the
opium trade has all but disappeared
pylons distribute electricity to the
city's solar panels are now everywhere
powering irrigation pumps allowing more
crops to grow you quickly appreciate
this war weary nation is for the moment
accepting a more authoritarian
leadership in exchange for stability
well here in Cabool the streets are
relatively safe the checkpoints have all
gone this the reopening
the function
s when I watched it I thought it might
be a spoof because it sounded and looked
like some kind of thing Alan Partridge
would do with the cheerful music uh you
sort of portraying the place now as a
safe haven everyone can Trot down to do
you regret with hindsight putting out
that video and the way you put it out
yeah
um thank you for inviting me on it's
important to put your hand up and
acknowledge errors however
well-intentioned uh you and I have
spoken many times I stand up I speak my
mind I try and find Solutions especially
on the international stage and I'm very
very sorry that my reflection of my
visit could have been much better worded
and have been taken out of context I
have written subsequently about the
wider issues there I mean the background
to this as I think you're aware I lost
my brother in the 2002 Bali Terrace
bombing that Drew me to visit the
country many times over the last decade
to understand what we were doing but
sadly see the demise of the efforts
there
um and uh I understand that the whole
issue of Afghanistan remains very raw
especially with the veterans who serve
after our department during the visit
last week I was astonished by what I saw
I went to something I did not expect to
see an eerie calm a visible change in
security corruption and an opium growth
which I felt obliged to report and could
have been better reported absolutely but
I also thought a very vulnerable economy
and this is the important point that
will collapse without International
intervention there's no doubt about it
it'll turn the country back into a
failed State okay but
you and I have talked as you said many
times about a number of issues right
normally you've been a smart Observer
and commentator on uh stuff that's going
on around the world I just think this
time you just seemed to have uh lost all
perspective of how this was going to
play out with people I don't think I've
ever seen anything quite like this video
for the reaction is provoked You've Got
The Spectator which is a conservative
magazine uh calling you uh basically a
Taliban useful idiot
um you've got MP standing up in the
Commons on all sides condemning what you
were doing you've got the Prime Minister
this is himself from what you were
saying you've got people like Bill Neely
one of the great foreign correspondents
of this country's ever had saying an
astonishing piece of propaganda utterly
ignores the rights of lost life chances
of half the population not to mention
them a disregard for ethnic minorities
despised by the new rulers maybe to buy
a server reconsider his analysis once
his heat stroke has passed and then you
had other cars respondents talking about
this incident which happened in the last
24 hours a group of women come out on
the streets of Kabul today to protest
against the taliban's closure of all
beauty salons in Afghanistan they
chanted bread work Justice the Taliban
used water cannons and gunshots to
disperse the protesters and you know one
of the many things you say in your video
you talked about potentially using
women's right to some kind of bargaining
tool with the Taliban which caused
complete outrage because women's rights
should never be used as any kind of
bargaining tool they should be afforded
because they're entitled to women's
rights do you I mean at the very least
on that point would you like to have the
opportunity to withdraw that
well you've made so many points today
maybe I could have an attempt to respond
you know the strategy that we have at
the moment from shouting from afar is
clearly not working we abruptly
abandoned the country in 2021 and my
simple call to action was to see our
Embassy reopen just as the EU Embassy
has opened as well and we need to pursue
a more direct strategy if we are serious
about helping the 40 million people who
feel abandoned I I understand that there
is a natural inclination given that
taliban's ruthlessness its
interpretation of sharia law it's
tripping to women and girls and in the
immense sacrifice that we made uh with
our brave service Personnel you know to
distance ourselves and to say no we're
not going to have any truck which I
think is what you're implying but the
awkward truth that we felt faces that we
handed power to the Taliban we seated
that path we abandoned those 40 million
people we said we're willing to commit
and help and if we are serious about uh
returning there in any form whatsoever
to provide support that requires
engaging opening do you accept that
women's rights should never be a
bargaining tool
it I I would absolutely agree that that
would be our position I'm making it
clear of what I believe the taliban's
position is which we then need to make a
judgments with respect to bias why
should we give us stuff about what the
Taliban thing there are a bunch of
hideous they're a bunch of hideous
misogynists who have taken the country
in terms of women's rights back to the
Stone Age quite literally actually in
some cases women there are being
oppressed on a daily basis
and you're talking about using women's
rights as a bargaining tool I'm simply
saying surely on reflection you wish you
hadn't said you need to let me finish
you need to let me finish Pierce
otherwise I won't be able to get my
point across okay first thing it is the
Taliban that I'm saying I'm reporting
that's what I saw happening is the
Taliban are wanting to use this as a
bargaining tool they clearly don't care
about women's rights there's certainly
the hardliners don't and there's a
concerned within the Taliban itself that
many of them may Sprint her away and
join Isis K that's why we're seeing more
restrictions coming in what we're also
seeing is the situation with with
women's with girls education is actually
worse when I discovered half the
children under the age of 11 don't go to
school at all
I'm trying to interrupt but if it's
worse than you discovered how on Earth
could you put yourself to a promo video
with all that cheerful music about what
great guy is the talibana I just don't
get it
well you can keep referring back to the
video sir I made it very very well you
put it out that was my error but I've
written further than that I could only
say so many things uh in in that video
and I make it very very clear I put my
hand up and say it could have been much
better done but I've also seen very
clearly too that our current strategy
that we're adopting at the moment is
allowing the Taliban to then run this
country in a way without any influence
whatsoever because they're not listening
can you say okay but look you say the
Taliban are doing everything to ensure
the prosperity of Afghanistan is people
that's just a total lie they're not
what I'm saying is is that if we want a
we are serious about supporting women's
rights if we're serious about getting
those schools reopened then there needs
to be quiet engagement the shouting from
afraid is not working in fact I'm not
shouting from afar I'm just saying that
yours your statement that they're doing
everything to ensure the prosperity of
Afghanistan and his people and they're
no longer a terrorist organization those
statements simply aren't true they're
consorting with lots of terrorists
I never said that they were there were
never a terrorist organization never
used those words they were the this was
the very organization that harbored the
very people that killed my brother so
please don't put words into my mouth
okay if we want to have a serious debate
an awkward difficult debate of where
Afghanistan is going we spent more time
talking about Afghanistan in the last
couple of days because of my visit that
I'm pleased about and absolutely yes I
put my hand up and say that that video
could be done better you can keep
returning back to that video as much as
you like that doesn't actually get us
back to the bigger point of what we are
doing in internationally to help women
and children in that country given the
reaction to the video which is actually
as you know something that you put into
the public domain uh clearly had no idea
the reaction was going to provoke or you
wouldn't have done it but given the
cross-party fury about this given the
media theory about this given the fury
of so many people in Afghanistan given
there's now a report in the times that
there's a a plot currently being
undergone to remove you from your
position of chair of the defense
committee will you be considering your
position
I'm traveling with the defense committee
here in India where I am right now and
we've you know we're we're working very
well together there is no support for uh
any of what is going on back in the UK I
make it very clear I don't know how many
times I can say this to you pierce you
keep returning back to it you don't
allow us to move on I put my hand up you
know I step forward on many occasions
and say things perhaps which other MPS
won't say and occasionally yes I say
things the wrong way because of Twitter
a storm then comes about about it and I
have to deal with it I'll be very clear
the last couple of days are probably the
most miserable as a member of parliament
I got it wrong peers I don't know how
many times you'd like me to say that but
I stand by the fact that Afghanistan is
in a very bad place the economy suggests
something we have some difficult
questions okay can I suggest something
will you delete the video
I'm happy to do so sir I'm absolutely
happy will you do that immediately this
interview is over because that would
indicate you genuinely are remorseful
of course I am and I would not further
say that I'll put them put out a cloud
station clarification of a statement to
do so but there is an underlying message
uh that we've not spoken about
Afghanistan I don't know when you last
brought it up on your program it has
been abandoned the diffid budget for the
United Nations
with respect you haven't got a lecture
me about Afghanistan my brother was a
serving British Army currently served
Tools in Afghanistan so I'm very aware
of Afghanistan I've covered it uh a lot
over the last years I was extremely
critical of the way we withdrew uh with
the Americans from Afghanistan that was
a total debacle but I also happen to
think the Taliban are a bunch of
Ruthless wolves who have taken with any
of them the poor women of Afghanistan
back to the Dark Ages nothing
unfortunately you got used in some way
which provoked you to do that video
which has looked like it was promoting
the Taliban which I think was a
catastrophic error of judgment and I've
known you a long time I'd rather be
straight with you and tell you that I
think if the best thing you could do is
to finish this interview and delete that
video I'm gonna explain why you deleted
it I think that would go a long way to
putting people's minds at rest so you're
not some Taliban stooge which is how
people view it
yes it still doesn't answer the question
and I will do all that make that very
very clear as to what is our strategy to
help the 40 million people who feel
abandoned and we then seeded power to
the Taliban these are I'm afraid the
awkward questions that when everybody
has moved on from this storm right now
we have to still there are no listen I
absolutely agree there are very
important questions but doing a promo
video for the Taliban is not any way to
go answering them so I hope that you now
delete it and explain why you're doing
that and I appreciate you coming on and
doubtless we'll talk about other things
another time
thank you thank you on sense of next
does today's culture glorify mental
illness zooby thinks so and he reckons
we all should be more resilient he joins
people that debate next
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to today's Welcome Center
breaking news Tobias Elwood has
apparently now deleted the now Infamous
Pro Taliban video which he posted the
calls all the problems as a result of me
telling him to delete it so there you go
uh feminist author Caitlin Moran made
headlines last week by blasting Dr
Jordan Peterson telling GQ that she
fears for any man that a crisis turning
to him the fact is that many men in
crisis do turn to him and to others with
similar messages in a culture that seems
beset by anxiety problems an epidemic of
trauma a simple message of discipline
has found massive resonance but blaming
mental health seems to be a fig leaf for
all manner of celebrities sin so I'll be
living through a mental health crisis or
I'll be living through a crisis of not
having mental strength joining me now is
rapper and podcaster zubi and the author
and broadcaster Jenny Cleveland right
welcome to both of you zubi you've been
very strong about this you said a lot of
uh tough stuff I would call it tough
love and it comes from a place of
wanting to help people but you think
that there's basically a lot of people
who use Mental Health perhaps in a way
that it used to be stigmatized now in a
way as a sort of in a glorifying manner
yeah I think it's pretty nuanced I think
that there is genuinely a decline in
overall mental health and mental
well-being especially amongst younger
people and we could get into the reasons
for that at the same time there is also
an element of trendiness that is going
on with it in certain infections on the
opposite end and then I think on top of
it as well it's become
what's the best way to put this
um I think there is also that yes there
is an absence of resilience in that
people are not being as well prepared
for the World perhaps as they should be
and I think another thing that's going
on is this sort of pathologizing of The
Human Condition I call it which is
calling sadness depression calling a
pain or a heartbreak trauma
um calling just sort of using this
therapy language all of a sudden you
have teenagers who are claiming they
have PTSD and everyone's got trauma and
anxiety and depression and I think these
words are being overused and so that's
right I have a lot of agreement with a
lot of that uh Jenny I think the problem
is people I think you've got real mental
illness
to build about mental health and I find
that weird it's like well mental health
if you're healthy aren't you mental
illness means you're sick and need
attention and help you know clinical
depression is a very serious thing and
so on but I do I've seen a real Trend in
a lot of famous people who seem some of
them seem to have endless things wrong
with them they should then become front
page news or books or whatever it may be
and I the cynic in me says really you're
all suffering from all these things from
your Mansions well maybe they are
suffering from it I mean maybe in the
past people felt that they couldn't talk
about it and I think I think the
destigmatizing of these kinds of
problems is a good thing it is still the
case that um you know suicide is the
leading cause of death of men under 50.
um and it is a good thing that we are
getting better at telling people there's
nothing to be ashamed about if you if
you have these problems I'd agree though
that um I do think we we have a problem
where we are not encouraging people to
be resilient some of the most rewarding
things I've done in my life have been
daunting have been tough where I've had
to put myself out of my comfort zone and
I do think we need to encourage people
to fight there's a disconnect between
like if you take sport professional
sport right people are conditioned to be
incredibly mentally strong resilient
tough I don't know why we don't
transport that to regular life get into
schools with tough people going in there
and and trying to teach people mental
strength and resilience they're actual
things that you can be taught you can be
taught to be tougher and stuff but if
you talk in this language I'll
immediately have people reacting now on
Twitter right you're disgusting you're
inhuman no no I've brought up four kids
I've had lots of intense conversations
with them from time to time about very
difficult times in their lives and tried
to help them through it I'm a good
listener I think I encourage people to
talk all that is is fine but I also did
say it's a generational issue of young
people who just don't seem as equipped
to deal with normal life and I think
zoomy that a lot of what you're saying
it may sound like tough stuff it's a
tough love in a way we want people to be
better I don't think they're being
equipped to come out of school perhaps
and have the skills set for life yeah
absolutely and I think the the truth is
that the world is difficult life is hard
at a minimum every single person we know
and love including ourselves we're all
gonna die we're all going to experience
we all have a terminal illness sickness
right we're all going to experience
tragedy and that's just the way of the
world you're also going to come across
people you disagree with you're going to
hear things you don't like your good
people are going to be nasty to you and
harsh and so on and sure we shouldn't go
around being nasty and harsh towards one
another but you also have to recognize
if you're gonna if you're a teenager if
you're a young adult if you're going to
exist in the world with the 8 billion
people in it and all its complexities
you have to be strong and resilient I
totally agree and the thing is people
can mock people like Jordan Peterson and
Andrew Tay let's put aside the court
case we'll see what happens with that
when we're on an interview I did say
afterwards I found myself agreeing with
a lot of what he was saying you may not
like the way he says it and some of it
is unacceptable but we've got a clip of
one of the things you said example
do you believe depression is a real
thing I believe that feeling depressed
is real I don't believe depression as a
clinical disease is real no a lot of
people who are clinically depressed are
suffering with something in their life
and if you fix the problem in their life
perhaps they won't feel depressed but
it's not a disease but Andrew that's
situational Andrew You're simply wrong
if you think you are single-handedly
curing people of clinical depression you
are living in Cloud curcula so that's
one of the issues I had with it was I
think he goes too far with that I think
clinical depression is a very real
sickness that needs proper treatment but
there are other parts of that interview
where he talked you know and the reason
that young men in particular gravitate
to the likes of Tate and Jordan Peterson
and others and they're different
characters
um with different skill sets but they
these guys do try and give them a
message of empowering them to feel
stronger about life is that wrong I mean
the masculinity is not everything
masculine is now toxic apparently I
think that's very damaging problem with
that approach though is it gives the
impression that these issues are easy to
solve if you uh man up and pull your
socks up and if you can't solve these
problems by you know getting out of bed
making your bed and you know exercising
then um you you have failed and you are
weak and it could be incredibly damaging
for someone who's in real crisis who's
hearing that the solutions are simple
what I'm feeling isn't real I need to
just go and do that but actually there's
a great speech by Admiral mcraven the
great U.S Navy seal commander and he
does the making your bed speech he did a
commencement thing where he talked about
if you just get up in the morning
whatever your problems are and you make
your bed and you make it well it's a
great start to a day yeah and it's a
great speech I recommend people go and
watch it because I do think it's doing
the basic stuff in life bringing a bit
of discipline in order to life even real
Christ no no I'm not talking about
people who have a genuine mental illness
I'm talking about the vast ways of
people who just seem to find life
difficult now and exactly this is why
it's important for people to use words
correctly yeah right I was talking
before about what I call label inflation
if you're just feeling sad and you say
that you're depressed and you have
depression if you're a little bit
worried and concerned about things and
you're saying that you have anxiety or
PTSD PTSD and so on you're you're
diluting these terms so now it becomes
more difficult to separate someone who's
just feeling sad because their life is
not going well and they don't have
certain things in order versus someone
who genuinely has agreements we've got
to leave it there sadly it's interesting
debate it won't go away we'll have it
again in more depth but it's an
interesting debate I just want young
people to feel a bit more resilient and
strong because they'll enjoy their lives
more and I think social media has a lot
to do with why they don't and that's
another part of this which we didn't get
into great to see you both zubie and I
had a good old bust up on Twitter
earlier about covid haven't got time for
that tonight but we won another time
zooming I'm coming for you okay don't
worry I'm ready I'm ready uh good to see
you I'm censored next to brutal nickname
can really stick in politics which could
be very bad news for Sakia starmer I'll
explain why after the break
[Music]
thank you
good evening I'm Peters Morgan I'm
censored in New York City tonight up
here's Morgan uncensored in Kiev Ukraine
tonight on Piers Morgan has a special
edition from cancer tonight a special
edition appears more than uncensored
Martina navratulations do you believe
you can win this war so are you gonna
run again I think a lot of people are
going to be very happy yes I feel
betrayed they're trying to force you out
yes not only the coach but the other two
or three guys there around these
protesting just don't get it many of
them don't it's not slightly patronizing
I would call him
do you think we should have psychiatric
assessments I'd be there for weeks did
you keep quiet I'm trying to read a book
thanks bear and Chuck it where it
belongs in the bin
sexy where are they where's their
children
Maxwell agreed to be interviewed for the
very first time I obviously wish I'd
never met him you're shaking in your
head the British people are up in arms
Boris Johnson is out as British prime
minister the conservative party can
certainly win the next election can we
yes
this is the royalty question is did he
say yes I have taken drugs and they've
bent the rules to give them the Visa or
lied on the visa application form and
therefore got it
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
a woman is given to the man in marriage
Andrew You're simply wrong I've been a
terrible liar that's true I mean would
you be prepared to say that I've been a
terrible liar are you sorry you said
that
no I think it matters you should be
absolutely not you should be interview
adjourned
[Music]
is your favorite nickname that Trump's
giving us Rhonda sanctimonious or
meatball Rock I see new clown Tommy Fury
so please go easy on me bro please go
easy you weren't asked to give evidence
to the grand jury I have nothing to hide
I'm the only one that has been telling
the troops you had to come up against a
team and had a Russian player would you
shake that no chance no chance it's life
and death This Is War Pass Morgan
what went wrong she said well I've only
got two years and I said you'll have two
months if you carry on like this what's
your response to him the whole nation
deserves to know what happened you don't
drink never taken drugs you're stinking
Rich should we be concerned
real opinions real debate is about you
and your opinions if you're thinking
about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that's a joke
coming up on the talk Nigel farage slams
Coots for axing his accounts because his
support for Donald Trump and Novak
Djokovic doesn't align with the bank's
values and the home office issues a
security Alert warning one terrorist a
week will be freed from jail for the
next six months and it's revealed
Britain is Europe's work from home
Capital that's all coming up at nine
[Music]
welcome back to physical Grocers I'm
joined by my pack told me contributor
Esther cracker and Associates for Daily
Mirror Kevin McGuire welcome to both of
you so Kia stammer has been branded
circuit starva because he's confirmed
his government wouldn't change the
two-child limit on benefits now rather
than debate this Kevin I thought it'd be
quite interesting because you've been
boasting apparently privately that you
know every nickname of every politician
who's ever graced God's earth except the
ones you're gonna ask
what's up um
let's try it
oh Thatcher
yeah Margaret Thatcher the milk snatcher
who is known as Esther Greece piglet
oh um was it Cameron
yeah
yeah who was known as slick Willy slick
Willie American
Bill Clinton correct correct it was
known as The Gipper in America
I have no idea Ronald Reagan again
wow you're gonna blame your age in a
minute yeah I am who was known as a
human hand grenade here oh uh Liz Tross
correct yeah Tarzan
Tarzan here
terrible I know I'm sorry I take
politicians
it's an era thing Michael half the time
uh Blair yes
try something a little easier it was not
in America's the Donald
could it be true
that was really quite startling um so
private space firms Kevin including Jeff
Bezos his blue origin Richard Branson's
version of Galactic are now offering
civilians a chance to venture into space
now this could mean that we could have
the first ever Act of sex in space it's
always been outlawed for astronauts so I
guess my obvious question to you is
should the opportunity arise would you
like to be the first person to ever
populate in the strategy so I could ask
did the earth move for you
was was that out of this world I mean
not even sure yeah well we're not even
sure whether it's it's technically
possible but there are issues with
gravity yeah you'll move around well my
question is will I get paid right and
secondly will I get paid extra do you
want to be paid to have sex in space of
course I hate flying so if I'm going up
there to do all of that why does it
being paid for it make any difference
because it's most it suits my soul I
think if you hate flying it's probably
not one for you I know but you know that
lack of gravity is probably where you
could do the entire Karma
yeah
well it'll be the 62 mile high club to
be the first person to ever have sex in
space I would I wouldn't mind that on my
CV
um
it's quite a thing isn't it it's your
legacy it depends with whom you know if
I could write my own obituary I wouldn't
mind it being that rather than what is
likely to be the case that's true that's
true yeah
quite cool
um are you a fubber
uh yes sadly the farming is where a
person's distracted by their phone
during a conversation with others yeah
I'm a terrible father but I'm a kind of
quite proud father
no I would tell them
hold on I don't want to ignore you so
let me just finish this text and then
I'll give you my first sometimes I do
actually want to ignore people they're
being boring I'd rather be thubbing what
actually shows you can multitask you can
chat to somebody and you can look at
your phone and send a message you guys
think you're good men are terrible at
multitasking so clearly you spend on
your phones a day do you think oh about
four hours yeah really because you get a
screen time check every week every week
I dread to think it was like 25 hours a
day I mean it's a lot which is basically
in my office we sent emails we write
stuff and we we do work yeah I think I'm
an obsessive phone user and therefore
probably an obsessive Thunder well
somebody's got to keep you Elon Musk in
uh yeah
followers uh great to see you both thank
you both very much a nice light end to
the show uh interesting Tobias elbow has
now deleted his controversial video yeah
I mean clanger huge clanger he's a he's
normally a sensible guy he's got this
and he was a useful it's an island
Partridge video but nightmare great to
see you both that's it from me whatever
up to Keep It Uncensored good night
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign